now justice secretary Liz chaste has
announced a 12 million pound pay boost
for frontline prison staff in London and
the South East it's pulse of measures
aimed at averting a crisis in jails in
the face of riots falling staff levels
and low morale so would it work long
joined now by Fiat business Steve dag
worthy Steve thanks so much for joining
us this afternoon so we're going to see
a pay rise for some prison staff a 30
grand pay packet for new recruits do you
think it will be enough well I think
what's Nydia and I actually see this as
a staff retention rather than a start
recruitment drive that the fact is is
that we we need to redress the ratio of
officers against prisoners and at the
moment there are far too few officers
looking after too far too many prisoners
so the bottom line is is that we've got
officers that simply can't cope on the
wing and I think they were referred to
recently as cannon fodder I mean these
these band three officers are the
frontline wing officers who and who are
to say at the moment are fearing for
their own safety and going to work every
day so I think if the initiative brings
about the recruitment and bring and
redresses the balance then it can only
be a good thing but I mean there are
other ways of doing this to be honest
with you and you know there are there we
need to look at potentially who we sent
a prison in the first place and also
look at those who are risk assessed to
be safe to return to society perhaps
they should be allowed to be released so
that we can immediately adjust the
balance as opposed to this initiative
which is going to take years to to
implement I mean do you really think is
that it's a case of we just need to
release more prisoners is that is that
really the answer to this issue well the
answer is is our prisons are too full so
we have to relieve release the pressure
in the system I mean our prisons are
something like 111 percent over capacity
in some prisons it's 160 percent over
capacity so we have to relieve the
pressure in the system now it doesn't
take a brain surgeon to work out that
the only way you need anyway to do that
is to either build more prisons that's
going to take a while we get more
officers in that's going to take a while
or simply start releasing them and there
are prisons and there were thousands of
prisoners in empress
who are nonviolent I mean the Liz trust
this morning was saying that the cause
of this is the increase in violent
offenders in the increase in drugs well
drugs are coming in because there aren't
the security officers to stop the drugs
coming in in the first place and that
there isn't so much an increase in
violent offenders there's an increase in
white collar offenders who actually pose
no physical threat to society and once
they've gone through there or working
through their sentence and they've
completed their sentence plans and
they've been risk assessed by their own
system to show that they are safe to
enter the re-enter community perhaps we
should look at re-enter allowing these
people to come back into the community
under very close supervision which would
be far far cheaper than it is to keep
him in prison and will actually have the
effect of reducing the prison numbers
which is actually what's needed
I mean you've spent time in in prison
Stephen what is life like in jail we saw
pictures of riots we're seeing an
increase in the number of assaults and
the number of suicides I mean why is
things so tough in in jail well as a
company we represent very many prisoners
who are currently inside and I'm getting
horror stories that are coming out at
the moment I mean I was talking to a
prison governor after a shift recently
and I asked him how the shift went in in
the our conversation he mentioned he had
two near misses ie he managed to cut one
prisoner down before he died in hanging
himself and managed to put another one
out because he set fire to himself I
mean this is what this is this is the
the carnage this is the crisis that's
going on in prisons at the moment we're
seeing them in the press and we're
seeing on the TV where it's at and the
prison officers Association are saying
it that prisoners are actually running
the prisoners running the prisons and
officers are too scared to go on the
wing I mean this is we're a first world
country I mean this this this shouldn't
be what now prisons are about and it's
even worse because our system is
generating more crime actually because I
really ended is somewhere in the region
of nearly 50% and the cost of society of
that is 15 billion pound a year and I
think I think the government need to
take the first part of rehabilitation is
take responsibility for your actions and
the government need to take
responsibility for their actions in that
years ago they decided to cut the budget
this is this is the problem may have
cause they need to come to the voter and
say look we got this wrong but this is
where this is how we're going to solve
problem we're gonna save you money we're
going to reduce crime and actually we're
not gonna we're gonna have a system that
actually works okay okay Steve tag where
they I'm afraid you're going to have to
end it there but Steve dag where the in
prisons consultant thanks very much
thank you very much Edie